there were some fundamental of things
that were very similar to real life
first of all the way Logan Roy by the
way the name Roy was chosen as close to
French Hua for King so the way Logan
King ran his company was like a king uh
you know he didn't run it like a CEO or
a chairman or anything like that he ran
it like a king and all the executives
around him were courteous that's exactly
how Rupert Murdock has run his company
in my book many years ago now full
disclosure I had a chapter called the
Sun at the court of the Sun King because
Murdoch behaved like the Sun King it
wasn't a hierarchical pyramid structure
of the company it was the king of the
middle and the courtiers all the way
round so I think they got that right